I'm not gonna let somebody hurt
themselves at my expense
and I don't want someone to use me
to feel better about themselves
like I don't want to be a tool or a
puzzle piece in somebody else's show
like that I don't want to be an actor in
somebody else's play
um
I want someone to want to bless me with
a gift and be able to bless me with a
gift and I want to be able to fully
receive that gift knowing the heart and
soul behind that thing not that
somebody's got some guilt that they
couldn't do something else a long time
ago or they've been struggling so
they're gonna make sure you don't
struggle that's that means you're
getting used for somebody else's
benefits they can feel good and I just
want to participate in that